mes amis vous êtes ce matin des milliers
mais c'est une seule voie qui émane de
vous la voie d'une famille réunie
rassemblés autour de nicolas sarkozy
le moment que nous partageons est un
moment historique le moment de la
renaissance la renaissance d'une famille
politique qui a écrit quelques unes des
plus belles pages de notre histoire et à
qui il revient l'immense et redoutable
responsabilité de porter l'espérance
c'est le renouveau de la france merci à
nicolas sarkozy d'avoir rouvert ce
chemin du renouveau du rassemblement et
de l'unité
merci à nicolas sarkozy de porter cette
espérance
oui
grâce à lui et avec lui nous sommes les
républicains être républicain mes chers
amis c'est avant tout vouloir une france
respecter et une france qui sache se
faire respecter pour cela il est un oui
n'est que temps que nous reconstruisions
ensemble une vraie autorité républicaine
la france a besoin d'autorité les
français exigent ils la réclame ils
attendent l'autorité d'un chef d'abord
bref le contraire de ce président de la
république actuel qui abîme et qui
dégrade la france la france a besoin de
l'autorité de la fermeté d'un état
qu'ils fassent respecter les lois de la
république et il sanctionne ceux qui ça
n'a franchi ce bref le contraire de
madame taubira chantre de la culture de
l'excusé
qui place le délinquant qui place le
délinquant au même rang que la victime
la france a besoin de l'autorité d'un
état qui refuse de voir la nation comme
l'agrégation de communautés l'autorité
d'un état qui sache faire respecter des
valeurs de laïcité qui considèrent oui
qu'aucune loi religieuse ne pourra
jamais être supérieures aux lois de la
république nous devons
nous devons et notre mouvement devra
ouvrir ce débat avec courage pour
combattre l'avancé des communautarismes
il y à 115 ans
la république a imposé à la religion
catholique de se soumettre à ces règles
nous vivons depuis dans cet équilibre
harmonieux qui respecte les croyances
mais qui refuse de les imposer à ceux
qui ne les partage pas nous devons
aujourd'hui avoir la même approche avec
l'islam de france ce n'est pas la
république de s'adapter aux règles de
l'islam mais à l'islam de s'adapter aux
règles de la république
c'est pour cela que personnellement
comme nicolas sarkozy je souhaite que
nous marquions avec force un coup
d'arrêt à l'expression de ces
communautarismes qui gangrène la
république pour moi le voile signe de la
soumission des femmes n'a pas sa place
dans l'université lieu par excellence de
la science de la liberté et de la
modernité
l'autorité de l'état c'est aussi la
capacité de pouvoir choisir le nombre et
la qualité de ce que nous voulons
accueillir sur notre territoire ce n'est
certes pas l'attitude faiblesse le
gouvernement actuel qui capitule sur les
quotas de migrants qu'on veut nous
imposer l'autorité de l'état c'est aussi
sa volonté à faire aimer la france à
transmettre notre histoire notre
histoire et notre héritage ce n'est pas
l'expression permanente de la repentance
historique l'autorité de l'état c'est sa
capacité à assimiler oui assimilés ceux
qui veulent devenir français
ce n'est pas la nationalité
données même à ceux qui la rejettent
l'autorité de l'état c'est sa capacité à
combattre le terrorisme sans naïveté en
refusant sur notre territoire le retour
de ceux qui ont décidé de combattre par
les armes les valeurs universelles de
notre nation et de notre civilisation
l'autorité de l'état c'est la capacité
de l'école de la république à ne pas
placer l'élève sur le même rang que le m
l'autorité de l'état
c'est dire aux parents la nécessité d'un
équilibre entre droits et devoirs à nous
de restaurer cette autorité républicaine
l'autorité c'est le contraire de
l'autoritarisme l'autorité c'est la
garantie de la liberté oui les
républicains seront autour et avec
nicolas sarkozy
à partir d'aujourd'hui les moteurs et
les acteurs de cette indispensable
restauration de l'autorité au service
d'une france forte que nous voulons et
que nous aimons